hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar the orexin hypocretin
system and aging and cognition by dr.
jim fatal i'm christina doula bobrucz
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrys the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning to learn more visit lab roots
calm now let's get started this webcast
is designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered
following dr. fatals presentation to
enlarge a side window just click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window now if you
experience any technical problems either
viewing or hearing this presentation
just click on the support button found
on the top right of your presentation
window or you can report your problem
through the green Q&A button at the
lower left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker Jim fatal PhD associate
professor at the University of South
Carolina School of Medicine
Jim fatal received his PhD in
neuroscience from the Ohio State
University and was a postdoctoral fellow
at Vanderbilt University Medical Center
prior to accepting a faculty position at
the University of South Carolina School
of Medicine in 2002 he is currently an
associate professor in the department of
pharmacology physiology and neuroscience
and directs the schools medical
neuroscience course dr. fatal studies
the anatomical and neuro chemical basis
of age-related cognitive decline his
work has received continuous extramural
grant support since 2004 multiple NIH
shoots as well as private foundation and
industry sources he is a member of the
American Federation for aging research
national scientific Advisory Council and
in 2012 he received the USC Education
Foundation Health Sciences Research
Award he has served on several NIH grant
review panels and has also served on the
editorial board for the journal
neuropsychopharmacology in addition to
his primary interest in brains brain
aging Jim collaborates extensively on
projects related to the biology of the
neuropsychiatric disorders and has
received Young Investigator awards from
the National Alliance for research on
schizophrenia and depression and the
International Congress on schizophrenia
research dr. fatal has also been active
in neuroscience outreach efforts with
schools community organizations and
undergraduate institutions around the
state dr. fatal you may now breathe in
your beds near presentation Thank You
Kristina for that kind introduction and
thank you to everybody at loud breaths
for the invitation to speak at this
event it's a interesting format and I've
been looking forward to it now for some
time so the title of my talk today as
Christina mentioned is the orexin
hypocretin system and aging and
cognition
not the risk of being pedantic I'm gonna
start with a slide that I use for my
lecture on the hypothalamus to my
medical students and this slide reminds
us that the hypothalamus really plays a
key role in responding to a number of
homeostatic challenges it's the key
central nervous system location or
responding to a variety of different
aspects of challenges to our
physiological homeostasis and I included
this because it reminds us that the
hypothalamus plays a key role in
coordinating physiological responses to
a variety of these homeostatic
challenges and so for example in
response to dehydration
- alamos can sense this as an increase
in serum osmolarity and it can respond
to that with physiological mechanisms
such as increasing release of anti
hormone which allows us to retain more
fluid at the kidneys and also could
enact autonomic responses such as basal
constriction which allows us to maintain
blood pressure in the in the face of
decreased fluid volume but all these
physiological responses to these kinds
of homeostatic challenges are really
stopgap measures so in our example of
dehydration eventually you're gonna have
to find something to drink or else you
will die of dehydration and this reminds
us that the hypothalamus also plays a
key role in behavioral responses to
these homeostatic challenges and these
behavioral responses have effective
motivational and certainly cognitive
components as well and these are the
responses that have for which the role
of the hypothalamus has really been
under study and because of this this
role in responding to homeostatic
challenges of course we can think of the
hypothalamus as being a physiological
integrator the key central nervous
system physiological integrator site
we're responding to homeostatic
challenges now the hypothalamus is one
of the most heterogeneous parts of the
brain in terms of the different neural
populations that comprise it we've have
a long-standing interest in one
particular neural peptide system within
the hypothalamus and that's the erection
a neuropeptide system also known as
hypocretin and of course these neuro
peptides have two different names
because they were discovered roughly
about the same time in the late 1990s by
two separate groups one of the groups
gave them these neuro peptides the name
Wrexham's after the Greek word Alexis
because they're expressed in the lateral
hypothalamus the traditional feeding
center of the hypothalamus if you will
and the other great group gave them the
name type of cretins because they're
only found in the hypothalamus but they
do have a certain degree of homology to
the secreting family of gut hormone
peptides for the sake of simplicity I'll
use the term orexin for the rest of
today's talk there are two related neuro
peptides alexis an A and a Rex and B and
these neural peptides act on two
different g-protein coupled receptors
that have been identified
there's the orexin one receptor which is
selected for our XNA and
the erection to receptor which binds
both orexin a an erection be roughly
equal affinity both of these are
excitatory g-protein coupled receptors
no not long after the discovery of the
erections
they were functionally linked with
narcolepsy it was shown in post-mortem
studies that patients with narcolepsy
have almost a complete loss erection
containing neurons in the hypothalamus
and this is especially true of patients
with narcolepsy with cataplexy if soon
became clear that these are these
neurons have a role beyond just
regulation of sleep-wake cycles but they
also play an important role in feeding
and energy balance consistent with their
placement in the lateral hypothalamus of
the brain and they also play an
important role in several other
conditions including things like drug
addiction particularly psycho stimulant
drug addiction so over here on the way
you can see a couple of micro graphs
showing the the approximate location of
the orexin neurons in the hypothalamus
and so on the top you see a section
through the hypothalamus of the rat
brain and these Alexan neurons are the
black labeled neuronal cell bodies there
in the hypothalamus that kind of
surround the fornix this section has
been double labeled or another
neuropeptide that's found in the
hypothalamus melanin concentrating
hormone or MCH those are the brown
neurons that you see here in the
hypothalamus and we've shown this
because we know that these two neuronal
populations are kind of intermingle
they're in the same general part of the
hypothalamus but they're not co-localize
at the same level of single neurons
their separate neural populations and
then below that you see a similar
distribution in the human hypothalamus
with the black orexin neurons kind of
arranged around the fornix in the
hypothalamus and the brown MCH neurons
sort of being intermingled with because
of this wide variety of functions that
have been ascribed to the erections and
because of the their their placement
within the hypothalamus they've also
been described as physiological
integrators
so the hypothalamus as a whole plays an
important role in physiological
integration and this neuropeptide system
in particular seems to play a
an especially important and prominent
role in in several aspects of
physiological integration before I talk
before I introduce some of our data on
the orexin system I also want to briefly
introduce the basal forebrain
cholinergic system because I'm thinking
about the role of the erections and
modifying cognitive behavior which is
one of the main points of today's talk
we've shown that that much of this
interaction has to do with projections
from the erection system to the basal
forebrain cholinergic system so we're on
the Left we have a a sagittal view of a
Ratan bright red brain and you see a
cluster of neurons here located in the
basement forebrain its includes multiple
structures and they're cholinergic
neurons in this part of the basal
forebrain that send widespread
projections to the entire cerebral
cortex as well as to subcortical limbic
structures such as the hippocampus and
the amygdala and then over on the right
we see a lateral view of the human brain
and a cool section roughly in the plane
indicated by the yellow dotted line here
will show you a cross-section of the
human brain that looks something like
this the approximate location of the
basal forebrain cholinergic system is
indicated by the blue circles and again
these are corners at neurons that send
widespread projections to the entire
neocortical mantle as well as to some of
these limbic structures and this basal
forebrain cholinergic system plays an
important role in several aspects of
cognition including learning and memory
and certainly an attentional function
and it's been heavily implicated in
age-related cognitive decline including
Alzheimer's disease loss of corner Ahn's
is still the primary neuro transmitter
hallmark of Alzheimer's disease and
because of that there's a lot of
interest and has been a lot of interest
in the role of the cholinergic system
and cognitive function in general and in
Aging in particular it's been known for
some time that the lateral hypothalamus
provides a robust innervation of the
basal forebrain cholinergic system so
zamorski and colleagues have shown that
there's a robust projection bundle our
hypothalamus including the area that we
now know encompasses the erect
system to the basal forebrain
cholinergic system it was hypothesized
that perhaps this plays an important
role in relaying information on
physiological significance to the basal
forebrain cholinergic system this part
of the brain that plays an important
role in cognitive function however I
wasn't known for a long time what the
phenotype of that input on the
hypothalamus to the basal forebrain
cholinergic system was in other words
what neurotransmitters what neuro
peptides are part of that relay from
life alamos to the basal forebrain and
so one's making about the world the
potential role of the orexin system and
modulating cognitive function we began
by looking at inputs from the erections
to the basal forebrain cholinergic
system and as you can see here on this
series of photomicrographs what we're
looking at is neurons that are positive
for choline acetyl transferase the
enzyme for zero point synthesis and the
marker for cholinergic neurons in the
basal forebrain those neurons are
labeled here in brown and the arrows
indicate fibers that are positive for
our XNA so these are fibers that are
coming from the hypothalamus and
projecting here to the basal forebrain
and you can see that there is a robust
innervation of these collage ignorant in
the basal forebrain from these these
wrecks and positive fibers coming from
the lateral hypothalamus and so there's
a neuroanatomical substrate for the
erection system of the hypothalamus to
interact with the basal forebrain
cholinergic system in some early studies
we decided to simply look at the effect
of
orexin a on release Alessio coin within
the cortex and specifically the
prefrontal cortex and so in animals we
did perform in vivo micro dialysis do
open google micro dialysis we had one
micro dialysis probe centered within the
basal forebrain where the cell bodies
are of these cholinergic neurons and the
second micro dialysis probe was in the
preclinical cortex of these animals
where we measured acetylcholine release
and so we use the basal forebrain probe
to deliver our X in a into the basal
forebrain and then monitors release of
acetylcholine within the prefrontal
cortex and as you can see from
this grass delivery of orexin a into the
basal or brain produces a significant
and robust and dose-dependent increase
in release of acetylcholine within
within the prefrontal cortex indicating
that the erection system not only
provides a robust input to the basal
forebrain but it's capable of activating
the basal forebrain as indicated by an
increased release of acetylcholine in
this case within the prefrontal cortex
so we wanted to place this in a more
functional context in other words under
what conditions might the orexin system
play an important role in activating the
basal forebrain corner it exists so we
went back to in vivo microdialysis
and what we did with our animals was we
trained we a mildly food restricted them
and then we trained into associate an
environmental manipulation which in this
case was sudden darkness in the
microdialysis testing room with
presentation of a palatable food in this
case a piece of sweetened cereal now
when you do that under normal conditions
and you do this repeatedly so this
becomes sort of an entrained stimulus
well for these animals as you can see
here in the blue line that that
manipulation the darkness cereal
manipulation produces a robust and
repeatable increase in acetylcholine
release within the prefrontal cortex
which we interpret as the animals are
paying attention to a stimulus in their
environment that's important and in this
case is related to a homeostatic
challenge these animals are hungry
they've been restricted and then we
looked at the ability of pretreatment
with an erection one receptor antagonist
to modify or block this increased
release of acetylcholine in the
prefrontal cortex and so the the drug
that we used was this SV compound SP
three three four eight six seven a
widely used selective or x + 1 receptor
antagonist and you can see that when we
pretreat these animals with either the 3
or the 30 milligram per kilogram dose of
this erection one receptor antagonist
they completely block the increased
release
acetylcholine in the prefrontal cortex
produced by that darkness serial
stimulus okay so the erection one
antagonist delivered systemically
completely blocks the increased release
of acetylcholine produced by this
darkness serial stimulus we also wanted
to make sure that this is acting within
the basal forebrain could it be acting
in a variety of different areas other
parts of the brain that receive Rx and
inputs and then project that to the
basal forebrain so again we went back to
the dual problem in vivo microdialysis
approach and we used the the basal
forebrain firm to deliver on the
erection one receptor antagonist
directly into the basal forebrain and
again as you can see here in this graph
that completely blocks the ability of
the darkness serious serial stimulus to
increase release of acetylcholine within
the prefrontal cortex suggesting that
orexin inputs to the basal forebrain are
sufficient to explain the effects of
this this neuropeptide system on
activator to see lakorn release in this
context now not only does pretreatment
with the erection one receptor
antagonist prevent the release of
acetylcholine the response to this
stimulus but it also produces an
increased feeding latency when these
animals are presented with palatable so
you can see here there's a dose and an
increase in heating latency with the
orexin one receptor antagonist normally
these animals they're hungry as soon as
they and this is in a trained stimulus
as soon as they to exceed the palatable
food they're all over it and eating it
and we see a dose-dependent
increase in that latency with the
erection one antagonist and again
potentiation of this acetylcholine
release does require the Alexa one
receptor acting at the level of the
basal forebrain now we're really
interested in cognitive implications of
this interaction between motor extant
system and the basal forebrain
cholinergic system so certainly the
ability of anorexia antagonist to block
Co choline released in these conditions
is it's suggestive of a role in
cognition but we wanted to really drill
down on that and so in collaboration
with Josh Burke at the
College of William and Mary Josh and I
have been collaborating on this project
for a number of years now we looked at
the role of the erection one receptor in
in attentional function using a signal
detection task and so as you can see
here over on the Left we're looking at
the VI or the vigilance index in this
attentional task here on the y axis on
the x axis is the log of signal duration
and you can see here that now when these
animals are treated with the SP compound
the erection one receptor antagonist
there's a dose-dependent
decrease in vigilance index which is to
say that these animals are
underperforming their performance
decreases on this attentional task this
vigilance task when the pre treated with
the erection one receptor antagonist and
just as we saw that intra base Alice
administration of this antagonist blocks
acetylcholine release so we saw that
interface Alice administration of the
antagonist also produces same
attentional impairment that we saw with
systemic administration of the erection
one receptor antagonist again this
indicates to us that the erection that
the erection system and particularly
through the erection one receptor plays
in a key law in this potentional task
which we know is dependent on the
caloric system and there's other
evidence for a role for the erection
system in several aspects of cognition
and particularly attentional function so
for example Lam and colleagues have
shown that erections activate blammo
cortical terminals the manner that
corresponds to attention in the same in
a similar fashion as nicotine the same
Flamel cortical terminals interestingly
it's been known for some time that
narcoleptic patients and remember these
are patients that lack erection
neuropeptides
these narcoleptic patients show
attentional deficits during periods even
during periods of normal wakefulness
it's also been known for some time that
narcoleptic dogs show these degeneration
in the basal forebrain and this was
known before their own before the
erection system was even discovered now
this is really interesting because again
i'm ties back to the role the potential
the erection system interacting with the
basil although it might suggest that the
deficiency in erection transmission
might ultimately lead to degeneration in
in in the basal forebrain and perhaps
within the basal forebrain cholinergic
system itself and then finally when
bring it back into the context of
age-related human disease it's been
shown that erections appear to be were
reduced in certain manifestations of
age-related cognitive decline including
in Alzheimer's disease and so we took
this back into our attentional tasks and
I should point out that this is a an
attentional task that's been that's
based on a cast that's been valid valid
ated in humans and then adapted to our
rat model so this is from a paper from
listing and colleagues this is a group
that includes Morton Sardar one of the
pioneers in this in this task and a
sustained attention task is well in the
animal version of this the animals are
presented with a signal or a known
signal and then following a variable
delay there's a animals our cue to
respond to either that signal or the non
signal by the levers extending out into
the Opera box where these animals
perform tasks now if it's a signal trial
and the animal presses the signal lever
that animals that's considered a hit and
animals were rewarded for that in this
case the animal whooshes water reward is
their animals that they're mildly
dehydrated or water deprived if he if
the animal chooses the signal lever and
it was a non signal trial that and
that's considered a false alarm
the animals not reward by the same token
on non signal trials if the animal
selects the non signal lever that's
considered a correct rejection there was
no signal the animal would ordered no
signal on the other hand on a non signal
trial animal it's the signal lever and
that's considered a false alarm and I
should point out that I think I'm man to
spoken underneath on these signal trials
if the animal selects non signal lever
that's not that's considered a Miss so
you have a variety of different
responses here you can make this task
more difficult by doing things like
decreasing the signal link and you can
do other things like increasing the
delay between the signal and the cue to
respond you can also make it more more
difficult by doing things like
introducing a distractor so this is a
task that's uh that's modifiable based
on the human literature modifiable
forgive for animal studies and allows
you to perform a robust investigation of
neurobiological substrates of
attentional function so getting back to
the task now we return to the
possibility that the erection system
plays an important role in attentional
function and we did this by looking at
the my introducing the distractor this
is one of the ways that you can make
this task more difficult in addition to
paying attention to be the panel where
the signal will of an on signal is
located there's a flashing house light
in the back of the opera chamber that
can be a distractor to the animal so in
the presence of this distract of the
animal the attention performance of the
animals in this task tends to decrease
and that's reflected in this graph by an
upwardly directed bar so this black bar
for example right here in the upward
direction indicates decreased
attentional performance due to the the
presence of the distractor on the
important point here if I can direct
your attention over to the black bar on
the white side of this graph is that
intra base Alice administration of not
the attendant agonist ow but of the
actual peptide orexin a familiar AIT's
the distractor induced attentional
deficits seen in this task and so when
you put Alexa a directly in the basal
forebrain that deficit that attentional
deficit is animals show in response to
the distractor is overcome another way
can make this task more difficult is by
doing something to the cholinergic
system in these animals remember that
this is a task that's heavily dependent
on the on the integrity of the basal
forebrain cortex system and so in this
case these animals were lesion they
received
region at this 192 IgG Sabourin this
produces a selective loss in this case a
partial loss of a corner turn-ons within
the basal forebrain and again we recall
that this loss of quartered at neurons
mimics a the primary neurotransmitter
correlate of Alzheimer's disease not
surprisingly when you lesion what is a
partial lesion of the cholinergic system
performance in this task and again the
upward facing bar indicates decreased
performance during the distractor
performance in this task is diminished
by this corner of equation and what
we're showing here on the x-axis is a
dose-dependent amelioration of those
deficits are those attentional deficits
in this task when we directly put our X
and ay into the basal for line and again
this is data coming out of the lab Josh
Burke at William and Mary my
collaborator so just to summarize we've
shown now that orexin antagonists impair
performance on a cholinergic dependent
attentional task and we've also shown
that increased orexin signaling by
directly putting Rex in a into the basal
forebrain improves attention in caloric
leash and animals so that that set of
data will occur I think produces a nice
demonstration of the potential role of
the orexin system in cognitive and
particularly attentional function and
suggests a particularly prominent role
for the basal forebrain cholinergic
system in mediating orexin effects on
attentional function but we really
wanted to bring this into the context of
aging and in looking for a place to
start in there so it's been known now
for some time clinical studies have
shown that with aging oftentimes there's
altered caloric intake changes in energy
balance and unexplained weight loss a
variety of physiological changes that
are suggestive of alterations in
hypothalamic function and in fact it's
been shown that oftentimes these
physiological changes predict and
precede dementia with a lag period of
one to five years or more or more
now there are a variety of other
physiological alterations that can also
occur with a with agent certainly
changes in state wake cycle operations
and fluid balance all of these are
suggestive in general of hypothalamic
dysfunction and perhaps in particularly
in particular perhaps especially things
like changes in sleep wake cycle and
changes in energy balance suggestible
alterations in the status of the orexin
system we're aging and so in thinking
about this potential relationship
between aging brain pathology and
changes in energy balance changes in
food intake that might ultimately lead
to unexplained weight loss which seems
to be a predictor again of subsequent
cognitive decline we really decided to
focus on the potential role of the
orexin system in aging and it's been
shown from the human clinical literature
that there does appear to be a certain
degree of erection loss in age-related
neurodegenerative conditions such as
Alzheimer's disease and Parkinson's
disease now in thinking about the the
relationship between changes in energy
bounds changes in body mass and and
cognitive decline I like to share this
quote from dr. Buckman one of the
authors of these one of the papers on
the relationship between loss of body
mass index and cognitive decline in
aging says that although a loss of body
mass we may represent a true risk factor
from disease they think a more likely
explanation is that factors associated
with the development of Alzheimer's
disease also lead to a loss of body mass
with the latter serving as a phenotypic
marker that can be apparent prior to the
onset of clinical dementia you know
there was any may be there may be common
mechanistic mediators between parts of
the brain that degenerate and account or
changes in energy balance unexplained
weight loss with aging and parts of the
brain that subsequently do generate and
account for the cognitive decline that's
associated with Alzheimer's disease so
we began by simply looking at the status
of the orexin system in our age animal
model and when I say age time
rats that are in the 26 to 30 month or
category these are fairly old animals
and we began by simply looking at at the
numbers of orexin neurons in the brains
of these old animals so we're on the
left of this the left photo micrograph
you can see orexin
positive neurons within the hypothalamus
of a healthy young animal and then over
on the right we see the same image to
chemistry and from an old animal in this
case a 26 to 30 month old animal you can
see just with the naked eye that there's
a market reduction in the numbers of
orexin neurons in the brains of these
old animals we performed unbiased Astari
ology to get an unbiased estimate of the
total number of orexin neurons and are
in the brains of our aged animals and
some market reduction significant
reductions in in both the medial and the
lateral banks of the orexin neurons
there's been a suggestion in the
literature that these this neural system
might have different functions
associated with the medial versus the
lateral banks of these neurons but we
see decreases in both of those as well
as about 40 to 50 percent decrease
overall in the numbers of our Exton
neurons and using in vivo microdialysis
was also shown that there's a decreased
level of the neuropeptide orexin a
within the prefrontal cortex of our old
animals so these animals have lower
levels of orexin in the prefrontal
cortex they don't respond to
depolarization with high potassium in
terms of increasing the release of our
ex ante so it does appear that the
numbers of our X and neurons are
decreased in the brains of our old
animals now oftentimes with with a loss
of a neuronal system or partial loss you
may get compensatory sprouting and we
wanted to make sure that wasn't
happening happening with the erection
system and so we looked at in this case
Alexan inputs again to the basal
forebrain caloric system in our aged
animals to see if there's any
compensatory sprouting in other words
even though they lose somewhere X and
neurons or there still is there still a
similar level of innervation of this
brain area in our animals and the short
answer that is no as you can see here on
this
bigger on the white photo micrograph
there's a market reduction in erection
positive fibers around these corners in
neurons here showing here on brown in
the basal core line of our older animals
and we've quantitated this by looking at
points of apparent a positional contact
between our X and fibers varicosities on
our X and fibers and cholinergic neurons
within the basal forebrain and shown
that of anything the degree of loss of
innervation of the orexin system by
erection of the corner deck system by
orexin neurons and aging is is even
greater than the degree of cell loss of
Oryx and neurons agent and so our aged
animal or aged animals represent a nice
model of reduced erection innervation of
the basal forebrain cholinergic system
in aging one question of course is the
specificity of this hunt atlantic cell
loss oh we're just losing wrecks and
neurons or we do we have widespread loss
of a variety of different clinic
hypothalamic neuronal types in aging and
so we again we looked at the status of
the MCH Nolan concentrating hormone
neurons which are similarly located
within the hype of balance and we could
see that in our aged animals there's a
significant although much less robust
loss of MCH containing neurons
suggesting that the degree of Wrexham
loss might be greater than some of these
other neuronal populations but it's not
necessarily selected all of them we look
at all neurons in the hypothalamus using
the pan a little marker new end we saw
that there was absolutely no difference
between our young and our old animals in
terms of the total number of neurons in
this part of the hypothalamus
again this suggests to us that there's a
perhaps not completely selective but a
preferential
loss of erection neurons that happens
with aging purely as a function of aging
these animals haven't had no other
manipulation done so again we wanted to
bring us back into the functional
context so we took our old animals and
we train them we while the mood
restricted them and then train them in
the same Casca that i described earlier
for our young animals so these animals
are trained with repeated presentation
of a palatable food reward in
conjunction with sudden darkness and the
microdialysis testing them and what you
see here with the red line is that when
you do that in these order with these
old animals
unlike young animals you see say
absolutely no quartic response to that
stimulus however we were able to restore
the cholinergic response to that food
paired stimulus in the brains of our old
animals by directly administering exons
or XNA into the days of forebrain via a
micro dialysis we restored a normal
college student at ik irrelevant
stimulus by putting Rex in a back into
the basal interestingly we also showed
that we could restore the cholinergic
response not just by putting a resume
that into the basal forebrain but also
by putting it into the prefrontal cortex
so the basal forebrain inputs to the
propellant cortex might be part of a
loop in which orexin delivery inch in
either area might activate this loop in
a way that we stores a normal corner
response to a homeostatic stimulus and
it does appear that there might be a
possible glutamatergic component they
haven't shown the data here but local
administration were XNA and in the basal
forebrain also does produce a local
increase in glutamate release now we
call that treatment with the erection
one receptor antagonist increased
feeding latency in our young animals and
similarly with our old animals normally
have a greater feeding latency in
response to presentation of this
palatable food Lord and that feedly
feeding latency was decreased to young
control levels when we directly put
orexin
a back into the basal forebrain of our
and this instead just reminds us that
the deficit in our old animals or own
vehicle treated animals reminiscent of
our young animals created with your X
and one receptor antagonist and then
again our old animals treated with
Alexan a into the basal forebrain
show a repeating latency that's reduced
to the level of young control
well we also wanted to restore orexin
innervation in a lexan function if he
could over an extended period of time
and we decided to use a lentiviral
approach in order to do this so we
constructed a li lentivirus
that that were that made pre pro
erection under the control of the PG k
promoter and as you can see here with
this photo micrograph and yet the right
administration of as lentivirus into the
hypothalamus of these old animals
markedly restored orexin innervation of
these brown quartic neurons in the basal
forebrain and again why maintaining the
degree of this by looking at a points of
apparent am positional contact between
orexin fibers and cholinergic neurons
pousada trim with the pre pro erection
virus markedly up regulated erection
innervation of the basal forebrain
quartic system suggesting that this
might be a tool for restoring erection
regulation of the base or bank or attic
system in our aged animal model now not
only are we interested in erecting
inputs to the base of forebrain but
we've also developed an interest in the
role for xing inputs to the insular
cortex particularly as it relates to
aging the insular cortex has been
described as as as homeostatic cortex or
interoceptive cortex part of the cortex
that's important we're having the sense
of the physiological status of the body
and it does receive normally a fairly
significant erection innervation in our
control animals or age control animals
as you can see here on the left
there's a market loss of erection fiber
innervation of the insular cortex so
nuts and fibers are labeled in black
right here and then as you can see here
on the lake but lentivirus
the prequel Rex and lentivirus restored
erection innervation of in this case the
insular cortex and we were able to
quantitate by lick this by looking at
total orexin
a positive fiber link and you can see
here that our aged
sense virus treated group had a mark and
up regulation of x and positive fibers
here and the insular cortex to get
relative to young the young control
group and Y C and the Y
s group here are young animals that were
treated with a bull Rex and anti stance
expressing lentivirus
and then over here on the middle figure
we see that that not only did the virus
restore orexin expression in the insular
cortex but those aged animals been
treated with the sense virus the
pre-core xing virus showed a reduced
latency to feed in response again to
this palatable food reward compared to
the age control animals on the other
hand young animals treated with the anti
sense virus for an increased really
latency to feed relative to young
control animals and there was a highly
significant correlation between total
wreck sent by the link within the
insular cortex and feeding latency we
also looked at the effects on insulin
neural chemistry with restoring orexin
and the aged brain through this
lentiviral approach what we saw was that
aged animals that were treated with the
pre pro orexin virus and at least a
tendency for an increased release of
acetylcholine within the within the
insular cortex again following treatment
with the pre pro Rex and expressing
sense virus very little effect on
glutamate very little effect on gaba
release here in the insular cortex
although we did see robust alterations
in basal levels of both glutamate and
GABA and so in both cases we saw
increase to release increased basal
levels of glutamate and GABA in our aged
animals treated with a premolar X and
sense virus in the insular cortex we
also wanted to do longitudinal studies
to look at the effects a long-term
upregulation of
Rexton expression or restoration of
excellent expression in our aged animal
model and so in doing this we had aged
control animals in aged animals treated
with the pre Pro X and sense virus news
and both of these groups of animals will
put on mild good deprivation and as you
would expect we're looking at here at
body way on the y axis as you expect
both groups of animals lost weight when
they were mildly food
and in those animals were subjected to
virus surgery which they receive either
a control lentivirus or the prequel Rex
and expressing lentivirus and then they
will continue to and then mild food
about deprivation continued following
virus surgery all we noted was that in
our aged control animals those animals
that if anything an accelerated weight
loss following surgery whereas those
animals treated with the prequel Rex and
sense virus on their weight loss
plateaued after surgery and then when
those animals were put on a free feeding
diet in other words now they were
allowed to eat as much as they want the
aged animals treated with the pre pro or
exome virus they they over ate in a way
that allowed them to regain that lost
weight and their weight their there they
increased in body weight to levels that
were near what it was prior to surgery
and prior to the initiation of mild food
deprivation where as are aged control
animals a plateaued and if anything
continue to decline in terms of body
weight even after they were put back on
a free feeding diet in response to an
acute 24-hour fast then both groups lose
a little bit of body weight or aged
animals treated with the prequel or
exome virus bounced right back from that
manipulation whereas our other animals
continue to decline this really suggests
that though your excellent system plays
a key role in homeostatic responses such
as food deprivation and restoration of
lost body weight in aging and not
surprisingly restoration of orexin
signaling with the pre pro erection
virus also restored the caloric response
to our to our food stimulus in these
aged animals so just to summarize what
we've talked about so far in terms of a
big picture it does appear that a
decrease in orexin signaling is manifest
as a decrease in a corner chat function
we have a loss of an important activator
of the basal forebrain for our system in
our aged animal models as a function of
a loss of erection expression and that
may ultimately play an important role in
cognitive decline that's associated with
aging and this loss of a wreck since
ignorant also seems to plan
in changes in energy balance
perhaps decreased food intake and
decreases in physiological homeostasis
in general its function of aging which
may ultimately represent or manifest as
a loss of body mass and it's both of
these functions together are reminiscent
of what we see clinically often times
the outlet elderly populations well we
have physiological dysfunction that
precedes and predicts subsequent
cognitive decline and if it's true that
the erection system might be a common
mechanistic mediator of both changes in
physiological function and alterations
and cognition like aging it may be the
case that the erection one receptor
might be a potential therapeutic target
for treating age-related cognitive
decline and earlier stage where it's
manifest as alterations and
physiological status and so in thinking
ahead we're really interested in how the
orexin system is transcriptionally
regulated and alterations and that might
play a role in age so there have been a
few different transcriptional regulators
of erections that have been described in
our 6l or one for example fox a2 is
another one
although these might regulate Wrexham
transcription in opposite directions
plasma interested in the natural rule of
microglia as being a mediator of a link
between a decline and the erection
system with aging and a subsequent
decline in in the basal forebrain
chlorotic system it's been shown for
example that there are X and 1 receptors
located on microglia and we know that
that the base of our brain is a source
of a site of large numbers of microglia
around the quadric neurons and
activation of these our x + 1 receptor
these are excellent receptors on these
microglia through the our Genesis one
system appears to play an important anti
inflammatory response and we're also now
starting to investigate the wall of some
of these neuro peptides as their
administrative administered intranasally
this has been proposed as a potential
route of an administration of a number
of different hormone and neuropeptide
substances in a way that
Laozi to bypass the peripheral effects
of these substances and perhaps directly
access the brain so now we're starting
to investigate how our exons might be
interested administered intranasally and
how that might activate certain key
brain areas that are important and
physiological function and there been a
variety of studies that have already
looked at this to some degree so for
example we know that intranasal
administration administration of orexin
a in non-human primates appears to
ameliorate the cognitive deficits that
follow a period of sleep deprivation
it's also been shown that intranasally
administer administer directs in a
rapidly and effectively targeted a
number of different brain areas and in
one study enchanting humans it's
actually been shown to stabilize REM
sleep and ameliorate some of the
attentional deficits that are seen in
humans with narcolepsy and now the
cataplexy and recently my graduate
student Poole Calva and others in my lab
have been looking at the exo
intranasally administered Alexan a on a
variety of different neurotransmitter
neurotransmitter systems and brain
regions in our animal model and we've
shown for example that intranasally
administration intranasally administered
orexin a duck is capable of accessing
the brain it shows up in areas for
examples such as the spinal trigeminal
nipples one of the lowest routes of
entry of intranasally administered
neuropeptides into the central nervous
system but also shows up in other areas
that are cognitive function including
the prefrontal cortex and so we've shown
for example that the administration of
the Rex and a intranasally will activate
areas of the prefrontal cortex
such as the pre limbic cortex so now
we're looking at boss expression as a
readout or a marker for neuronal
activation ensure intranasal
administration of Rex in a increases
fast expression in areas such as the
pre-olympic cortex also increases fast
expression or activation in a granular
insular cortex as well as the other area
areas such as the perry lionel cortex
however it's not a global phenomenon
it's not like you put rocks in a and
then
intranasally and it just activates brain
regions throughout the entire brain so
for example when we look at the medial
orbital cortex or the Inca limbic cortex
and on the part of the peripheral cortex
we don't see any effect at all of
intranasal administration of our XNA and
in fact when we look at one specific
neural population within the cortex and
these are cortical gather urges
interneurons inhibitory interneurons
intranasal administration of the XNA
actually decreased loss expression in
this neuronal population as you can see
here in this photo micrograph a lot of
interesting we have some interesting
hypotheses as to what might be going on
in there
but the point here is that it doesn't
nonspecifically activate all brain areas
and neurotransmitter systems we've also
shown that it activates specific
components of the basal or brain
cholinergic system and so looking at the
vertical limb of the diagonal band for
example looking at cholinergic neurons
in the vertical limb of the diagonal
band we see that intranasally
administered orexin a as you can see
here in this photo micrograph increases
fast expression it activates these
coroner tech nods in this location then
the same thing is seen here in the
ventral pallidum / substantia nama nada
this is the CH 4 subgroup on basal or
vein corner at neurons to use no messy
limbs no inflation again we see that
intranasally administer or XNA activates
these components of the basal forebrain
cordage now not only does it activate
these neurons as indicated by the false
expression but also we can see that it
activates release of acetylcholine
within the prefrontal cortex in the
context of microdialysis studies so it
remains the weight administered orexin
a bruce's this robust and lasting lasts
for at least an hour increase in release
of acetylcholine within the prefrontal
cortex and we see a similar phenomenon
while the perhaps not as robust when we
look at glutamate release within the
prefrontal cortex as well and so
intranasally administered orexin a as
the ability to activate a number of
different brain areas that are cognitive
function as well as activate certain
neurotransmitter
systems including the colon recruiting a
seal coin that play an important role in
several aspects of cognitive function
and then I've been implicated in
age-related cognitive decline so a
conclusion then I want to bring this
back into the context of human aging and
age-related cognitive decline of course
there are a number of drugs that have
been used to treat Alzheimer's dementia
and other forms of age-related cognitive
decline and these drugs are highly
ineffective and that may be because the
current treatment focus is you look at
this graph here is played out here these
pages of patients now that are already
in the stages oftentimes of prank
dementia and the the manifestation of
this cognitive decline may reflect
changes in the brain that have occurred
years perhaps even decades prior to that
but we're gonna try to find a better way
to treat age-related cognitive decline
it's really imperative and we look
perhaps phenotypic manifestations that
ultimately lead to it to cognitive
decline and dementia all might reflect
changes in brain structures that
happened many years prior to the
emergence of Frank dementia and again
some of the phenotypic manifestations of
those all three of those brain changes
might be manifested as physiological
alterations including things like
changes in energy levels unexplained
weight loss changes in streetbike cycle
phenomenon that may reflect hypothalamic
degeneration and perhaps degeneration of
the orexin system in particular and if
we can identify those phenotypic
manifestations that may open up a new
window of opportunity or we can come up
with new treatments or for our elderly
populations who show those phenotypic
manifestations and perhaps address those
and arrest those at a stage prior to
wear those neuro degenerative processes
lead to cognitive decline
cognitive decline and dementia and
perhaps there's a particularly important
wall or Atlantic systems such as the
orexin
system and perhaps especially the
erection one receptor as as a
therapeutic approached
and without conclude by thanking the
people in my lab done this work this is
a number of graduate students and
technicians postdocs in my lab as well
as collaborators here at the University
of South Carolina and then my
collaborator at the College of William
and Mary where most of the attentional
work that I showed you today was done
dr. Josh Clark and some of the graduate
students in his lab and of course
thankful to the National Institute on
Aging this provided most of the research
most of the grant support for the
research that I've shown you today and
then prior grant suborders has been
provided by the American Federation for
aging research as well as the brain of
behavior Research Foundation and then
some of my students particularly my
undergraduate students in my lab have
been supported by Magellan scholarships
from the vice president's office here at
the University of South Carolina and
thank you all for your attention are you
happy to take any questions thank you
doctor fatal for not informative
presentation now before we get started
on the question and answer session just
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window
dr. fatal will answer as many questions
as we have time for okay dr. fatal our
first question is are the orexin neurons
actually dying with aging or is this
simply a loss of orexin expression a
really key question particularly this is
a really key question particularly as it
relates to our ability to step in and
perhaps save the orexin system with
what's aging and the short answer is we
don't know the answer yet to this
question there is some suggestion that
it may actually be a loss of orexin
neurons or neurons themselves are dying
because there does appear to be a
decrease in die northen in the
hypothalamus as well with Asia and we
know that Dino orphan is a nerve that's
co-localize with orexin in this part of
the hypothalamus so if there's loss of
not just wrexham but also Dino orphan it
may be the norm of themselves
are being lost or it could be that
there's just decreased expression not
just a erection but also perhaps dine or
and we're just didn't start going to
look at this by looking at some of the
transcriptional regulators of a wreck
single creep roller accent expression
with aging and so we're gonna look at
the rule at at the status of some of
these transcriptional regulators and
seeing for example is if there's
increased expression of some of the
factors that have been implicated in in
playing a role in transcriptional in
decreasing transcriptional regulation of
orexin expression with aging and if
that's the case and may suggest that it
may suggest that the neurons are still
there and that perhaps blocking these
transcriptional inhibitors of erection
expression might allow for recovery of
normal erection expression with age it's
still an open question at this point
they'll keep a dropper fatal in either
case why are the erection neurons dying
or down-regulating their expression yes
okay so again it may be the case that
there there are simply a down regulation
of the Rex and expression with aging and
well yet whether there's increased
expression of this transcriptional
regulator of the erection system and and
if there's if that's increased with
aging and maybe that that's playing a
role in dampening orexin expression with
aging and it may be that the erection
neurons themselves are not dying at all
and again if that's the case then
perhaps that represents an additional
therapeutic opportunity or salvaging or
saving the erection system you know in
with aging and so that's certainly
something that we're interested in
investigating as well okay next question
what other neurotransmitter systems does
the erection system interact with that
might contribute to its role in
cognitive function
yeah that's an important question as
well and of course we've focused heavily
not exclusively but heavily on the base
of or brain order system mostly because
of its implication and age-related
cognitive decline including Alzheimer's
disease but the orexin system has
widespread projections to a variety of
different brain areas and different
neurotransmitter systems that may also
play an important role in cognitive
function so we know for example at the
orexin system also sends a robust input
to the locus coeruleus the site of
norwich nergic neurons that send
widespread projections to the neocortex
and hippocampus these other areas that
are important for cognitive function we
know as the nor energic system itself
plays an important role and several
aspects of cognition including
attentional function we also know that
they were the erection system sends
robust projections to the eventual
malaria the sight of dopamine neurons
that contribute to the mesial cortical
limbic dopamine system which plays an
important role not just in motivated
behavior but also in several aspects of
cognition as well and so and maybe it's
almost certainly the case that the some
role of the orexin system in cognitive
function reflects these widespread
inputs to a variety of different
neurotransmitter systems in the
brainstem including as well as the basal
forebrain quartic system we focused
heavily on the basal forebrain
coordinate system because of its role in
aging but certainly all these other
neurotransmitter systems play an
important role as well but the exciting
thing is of course that if we can
restore orexin
neural transmission with aging we were
not just just restoring its ability to
activate the basal forebrain chlorotic
system but presumably would also have
effects on these other neurotransmitter
systems as well which may play an
important role in not just the cognitive
effects but also some of the homeostatic
or the physiological effects system with
aging we are almost out of time and we
only have time for one more question the
last question will be now dr. Peter you
are focused on the erection one receptor
is there a role for the erection two
receptor in these processes yes I think
the short answer to that is is there may
very well be you may recall I showed
that one slide showing that intranasal
administration of Rex and a actually
decreases activation decreases foss
expression within these GABAergic inter
neurons within the cerebral cortex is
parvalbumin positive GABAergic inter
neurons in the cerebral cortex why is
that the case how does that happen
well we know that that the base of or
brain contains not just clergy but also
a burger
yeah budget neurons and it's been
suggested that the GABAergic component
of the days of hoerlein may
preferentially respond to Rx and via the
erection to receptor and we know that
these GABAergic neurons of the basal or
brain project preferentially to
GABAergic inter neurons within the
cerebral cortex so it may be that
intranasally administered Rex in a May
through the erection to receptor
activate GABAergic projection neurons of
the basal forebrain which in turn
inhibit GABAergic inter neurons of the
cerebral cortex which might account why
we see a decreased activation of those
GABAergic neurons in the cortex in
response to intranasally administer
orexin a now would suggest that erection
is acting on both the erection one and
the erection two receptor within the
basal forebrain to modulate cognitive
function via both cholinergic and
GABAergic signaling it's an interesting
idea and it's something that we're
interested in further investigating in
the future
dr. fatal for that great question and
answer session and thank you to our
audience for their participation dr. if
they don't do you have any final
comments for our audience
one thing that I would say is just well
we're very interested of course in the
role of the orexin system with aging and
we really do think that this might
represent a unique opportunity to
address some of the relationships
between age-related physiological
dysfunction and subsequent cognitive
decline this may represent a key
mechanistic mediator between those
phenomena with the former preceding the
latter the cognitive decline by a number
of years and we're really excited about
the potential therapeutic opportunity
that might be might be opened up by a
rule for the erection system in that
relationship thank you all very much
thank you Dan doctor fatal and I would
also like to thank lab groups for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 23rd 2017
keep an eye out for that email from lab
rats
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we encourage you to
for without announcements your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event we hope you've enjoyed this
light broadcast in hope to see you next
time goodbye